[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
météo-france le refroidissement
budgétaire se confronte au réchauffement
climatique
depuis dix ans météo france a subi une
diminution continue de ses moyens
deux tiers de ces implantations
territoriales ont été fermées et ses
effectifs ont été réduits d'un quart
l'état n'est pas étranger à ces
évolutions puisque la principale
subventions qu'il verse à météo france a
diminué de près de 20% depuis 2013
pour dresser le bilan de ces évolutions
le sénateur vincent capo-canellas ce a
effectué un contrôle budgétaire de
l'opérateur dont les conclusions ont été
rendues publiques le 22 septembre 2021
dans son rapport le sénateur déplore un
désengagement de l'état auprès de météo
france au moment où le dérèglement
climatique rend les événements
météorologiques plus violent et plus
fréquents
il fait observer que si les budgets de
météo france étaient de nouveau revu à
la baisse les prévisions de l'organisme
public pourrait perdre en précision
en effet les capacités de calcul sont le
principal déterminant de la précision
des prévisions météorologiques
alors que météo france vient de mettre
en service s'est de nouveau
supercalculateur
l'opérateur doit déjà se projeter dans
leur renouvellement prévu à horizon 2025
le coût du projet pourrait s'élever à
300 millions d'euros mais seraient
susceptibles de générer environ 1,4
milliard d'euros de bénéfices
socio-économiques
de plus les ressources propres de météo
france vont être mis sous tension par
une concurrence plus intense stimulée
notamment par l'arrivée de géants du
numérique et du traitement de la donnée
le temps est donc très incertain à météo
france
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]